[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Hi,
I'm Maya Kaczorowski.
I'm a product manager in
container security at Google.
And I'm here at KubeCon
EU in Copenhagen.
And I'm so excited, and not only
because the food in Copenhagen
is absolutely delicious,
but it's actually
my second KubeCon.
Today at KubeCon we made
a couple of announcements
around partners, including five
partners that now integrate
with the Cloud Security
Command Center,
meaning you can see partner
results written directly
as part of the Google
Cloud platform.
We're going to go talk
to some of these partners
and some other
Google partners now.
So let's go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]